my next guest is a talented comedian and
actress whose new book
very fat very brave is out right now she
should add very funny
um to the title because she is and i
love her i'm talking about nicole byer
everybody
hey what's up nicole hi how are you i am
so good oh my gosh i love the flowers i
love the whole vibe behind you
thank you my roommate john millhiser uh
who's also a comedian he did this all
while i was doing my makeup
oh my gosh she's so good like an
interior designer
that's so cool i love your hair by the
way too thank you
beautiful yeah you've been out on the
front lines at protests recently
has that experience given you hope or
has it kind of deterred you like
i feel like i i know several people that
have gone and there have been different
kinds of protests and different
happenings in each one
so what has your experience been like um
it makes me feel hopeful personally
because
the protests have not stopped since may
and we're now in june
and i don't see them slowing down or
stopping
is there any particular moment that has
really stood out for you
like since may and now it's we're moving
into june um
no particular moments i mean it's just
really depressing to wake up
open twitter and go oh okay somebody
else is dead
yeah and i don't know if things will go
back to normal i mean
at least not for black people we talk
about it at nauseum
um i talk about it in my stand up so
like i don't know if there is like a
going back like if you're not
radicalized for forever
like you're part of the problem and i
encourage a lot of white people to read
white fragility it is
a wonderful book that truly breaks down
why why people don't want to talk about
race and why their discomfort seems to
uh you know take president over learning
and why like i think a lot of people
don't even notice it they don't see it
you know what i'm saying it's like if
you're in it you don't even see it a lot
sometimes and it's
not until you listen and have
conversations to where you see the
difference
and you hear the difference that you
actually go hmm
okay like you know i think that's a big
problem about it too is the ignorance i
think educating oneself is
probably the most important thing you
can do right now other than listening
yeah absolutely well we've this i don't
i don't even know how to switch subjects
on that but i'm going to try and get a
little lighter so we're not supposed to
there's no segway nicole i'm not that
clever um
but i do want to talk about because i
know you you pressed protested during
quarantine but you know we've all been
doing completely different things
maybe we would have ever done beforehand
too just to like stay
sane because on top of everything that's
going on there's just a lot of emotional
rollercoaster stuff happening and
um for me like i've started doing things
that i never did before or like things
with my kids that i never did before i
had time for
is there anything that you've been doing
during quarantine that you never did
before that you're like sure why not
well when i was a kid i remember roller
skating but i don't remember
like roller skating so i was like
i want to learn how to roller skate so
i've been learning how to roller skate i
kind of was
what that's amazing oh thank you
i screwed my knee two days ago
[Laughter]
because i almost crashed into a mercedes
oh
my god forbid that person i'm gonna take
my knee out before that
car um and then i also i've been pole
dancing
but i've been doing that that's hard
yeah it's so hard i
did this class on sunday and i'm so sore
but i can't i'm too heavy for that like
i can hold myself up
i'm much bigger than you and i can i'm
just telling you
from my experience i literally was like
nah this fat behind him for this
it's hard that if you can do that you
are incredible
it's so hard and i love it so much
because it's like a tangible thing where
you're like
oh i couldn't do this yesterday but now
i can yeah and it makes you feel sexy
it's like working out and it makes you
feel like a little well it
i imagine it makes you feel sexy when
you're doing it well um i wouldn't know
first hand i'm very mediocre
oh but it's it's i did it maybe it's
because i was drinking the time i tried
it but
yeah it was not good um but um
nicole i love your book too okay i have
your book here actually because
i love it i think it's amazing because i
that's one thing i love about you is
that you're so
honest and and in a funny way like
you're like this isn't
i mean so your book is called very fat
very brave um
and i think i'm kind of aware where the
title comes from because i'm a fan of
yours but for everybody that it
doesn't know why did you why did you
title it that so
when a fat woman posts on the internet
like
a picture of themselves in a bikini or
something revealing the internet goes my
god
you're so brave which is the fully
insane thing
to be like somebody who's wearing a
bathing suit to go swimming is brave no
they're just wearing the correct
articles of clothing to do an activity
well and it's almost insulting
because it was like like i always loved
them and they're like oh you're so
confident you just don't care and i'm
like what
the best is you don't care because i'm
like i spent
hours well and like i care about things
maybe just not things that you find
important but i was like
let's not write me off like that like
yeah it's funny how they they're like oh
you're still confident i'm like i'm not
confident i'm just like being
yes yes so frustrating
so it's very tongue-in-cheek i don't
think i'm actually brave but like i
would love to meet somebody who was like
ugh she actually thinks she's brave for
being in a bikini like i want to meet
that
person to be like i would have coffee
with that person
um well in the book um you have a way of
dealing with haters
and i want you to tell everybody what
that is oh i have so many different ways
um i have a particular favorite but
which one is your favorite um i like
whenever
you say that because this is my thing i
always say i think that's why i relate
to it i'm like
do you have that much time to sit at
home
yeah and like rail on me right now like
you like i don't even know you
you could have just ignored it and like
like i want your life
if you have that kind of time like you
turn around and go i'm sorry your life
is so little that you
have you're worried about me over here
like
yeah i i like that one too another one
i have is if someone calls you a cow you
just turn around and moo with them
i love that subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going